it's fun to put out songs like dibs and
love me like you mean it in yavoy and
like in their Bops and it's fun and this
record ironically has more Bops than
I've ever put out
um like it's it's the most upbeat record
I've ever put out but there's so much
more meat on the bones like you're
saying and I think it's because of The
Bravery that I found
in putting out the book and the kindness
that I was met with and putting out the
book and it made me feel really
confident and safe to continue to just
go there in whatever way I felt like I
needed to on the record because I I got
a roof over my head I got a warm body in
bed I don't think that growing up has to
be sad
I don't think that the process even
though it's messy I don't think it has
to be
shadowed by
this heaviness I and I used to think it
had to I I think part of the evolution
of a human and part of growing up and
being in your late 20s is just like
going man everyone goes through this and
what a comforting thought and feeling to
go I feel chaotic so much of the time
um
and like that's the point like that's
that's how you discover who you are is
like through the chaos and through the
juxtaposition of life and that doesn't
have to sound heavy
[Music]
I think therapy has been a very
necessary part of my journey the last
couple of years to re get to know myself
I think a lot of this record came from
the Stillness of 2020 I was forced to
stop being in forward motion and
get to know myself and hear myself for
the first time in a long time I learned
in therapy that my coping mechanism is
busyness which is really convenient for
me because I'm very busy and I wasn't
able to be busy for like a year and so
yeah therapy has just been a very
necessary tool for me and
um
it's to me it's something that holds me
accountable
and also helps like reframe some some
childhood stuff and it challenges me to
grow and to be better